I broke this song I was in my hotel room
and I was listening to by myself and I
was listening to cat's in the cradle
don't worry about it and for those of
you don't know what cats in the cradle
is it's a song sung by a guy and he's
watching his son grow up that's
basically what it is and I thought when
I listened to the song that was not my
experience so this is a song that's
closer to what my experience was raising
a son so this is what will my son was
born just the other day been home for a
week and I have to say
[Music]
it's not great just okay he looks like a
scrunched up monkey
he's already [ __ ] on my finger and
peated my mouth and I haven't slept in a
week I'm not gonna make it 18 years
but you had a baby and they sent your
home you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing he's the better my hands coming
out of the bath baby books don't tell
you [ __ ] those baby
[Music]
but will my son turned ten just the
other day
I'm officially his personal taxi another
terrible recital at his [ __ ] school I
have to pretend I care about other
people's kids you know that's [ __ ]
true Oh Tim was your son he was the
third tree from the right eye he was so
good in the play I couldn't keep my eyes
on I haven't seen my wife's vagina in
over a month
well you had a baby and they set you
home you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing every toy he wants cost 200 bucks
[ __ ] this [ __ ] kid I hate this
[ __ ] tears
really turned 18 and I gotta say I
didn't think that I would make it to
today he put in there see milk carton
back in the fridge he takes really long
showers but still smells like [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
he talks like an [ __ ] and steals my
room but I made it 18 years
[Applause]
[Music]
when you had a baby and they set your
home you don't know what the [ __ ] y'all
doing he thinks he won let the joke's on
him he's gonna wipe my ass soon he's
gonna wipe my ass
[Music]
so I said to my son and you guys map
sons I said to my god man you wipe my
ass when it already goes no I going out
he was like I'm not wiping your ass
that's gross and I said I watched your
ass use that's on you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]